subs up guys try not to wake the
the wife here hey the old ball and chain
right now
after dark don't normally film with this
hour but today is an exception for you
because i haven't gotten a video out
today
and i need to do it anyways enough of
that
let's talk about what i came here to
talk about which is
the greatest youtube kung fu
master guys i realized the other day
we've got a lot of them
in the guru space so we're gonna take a
watch
today up first oh boy
we've got mr brian
[Applause]
rose
now i'm not going to play too much of
this audio because brian
brian rose here has been known to take
down
clips that have this video in it because
he doesn't want you to know that this
exists
but i'll play a little bit okay you'll
have to imagine the side effects here
i'll do it for you
oh whoa brian well careful brian excuse
me i'm not trying to get this
uh video rated here any kind of kind of
thing let's
just check it out what's up with this
upward crotch shot
by the way brian who art directed this i
didn't even mean to talk about this but
you're giving me all the material i need
thank you brian
everyone put thank you brian in chat
also put in chat who you think
your favorite kung fu master is does it
mean
they would be good in a fight none of
these people would be good in a fight
but i'm talking about
who are you most entertained by the
upward top shot
wow okay all right that's enough with
brian i'm
i i don't want to push my luck here up
next ladies and gentlemen
we've got quite an amazing man someone
who's sort of a youtube
phenomenon i don't know if many of you
are old enough to have gotten this guy
his name is ashida kim
and this is his video called ninja
invisibility and he
actually teaches you to be invisible
with ninjutsu let's watch
technique here
cross step two
crosstalk
now behind the end
cross step crust crust oh my gosh
let's check this out because this man
first of all you can already tell
he didn't pit himself against a weakling
this man
right here i don't know who he is but
just from that stance
he's a formidable opponent
these by the way this is some great good
old 2010
youtube where the background noise is
louder than the voices themselves
it's like that used to be how all of us
watch youtube all the time
okay let's watch
oh my gosh that's incredible
this is wonderful this is not the kung
fu master although he looks to be
it let's watch what actually happens
is this fake this has to be fake right
no no i mean not fake but like
is it a joke is what i mean is it like
satire or is this guy real somebody tell
me in the comments i'm not too up today
this is my first time seeing these clips
up next we have a new guy steven seagal
okay you heard about about this guy now
steven seagal
famous you know kung fu action star
i don't know if he does i think it is
akido this man
takes his not his sport
too seriously he takes his life too
seriously you know a guy like that in
your life
wow incredible
well let's get let's get into this bud
just oh
wow he started
so what kind of technique is that you
know all in all of these you actually
become more impressed
with the people throwing themselves
around than you do with the actual guy
performing the art move
look at how completely bored
and serious he is
he looks like he's waiting at a
dentist's office right now
i guess just another day at the office
clocking in meanwhile all these guys in
the back
none of them are impressed and or they
all look up to steve
so much steven seagal that they all want
to be just like him
i've been in the martial arts for almost
50 years
wow this is pretty it's just
it's lame the way he's tossing them
about
so easily it's just like he makes it
boring it'd be kind of cool these other
guys are putting on a show
but the way he just is so just sad it's
this is
you could really put some sad music in
on this and it'd be like a depressed
scene of like a sad fire here put some
sad music on here like look at this it's
just
it's
oh my tragic okay so steven seagal
honestly
i like to see a little bit of effort and
that's not what i saw
from him i saw it with brian i saw it
with the sheet of kim
now our final contestant is someone you
guys may know
ladies and gentlemen dan lok yes
he's uh he's like the student of the
student of the student of
bruce lee or something i think that's
what he claims anyway he's got some
fighting skills too
well actually i couldn't find any clips
of him actually fighting it's just a
bunch of him like
showing people how to i don't know
ladies and gentlemen do we have a real
fighter here this is
more of what i was expecting somehow
what is this protection gear he's
showing you the inverted hook kick
watch this you can do the straight kick
i like this is like a
hook like that you can see aka
the old kick in the balls now you'll
find that kung fu people they love the
kick in the balls it's a
tried and true technique and in fact
it's not it's actually a vault it used
to be you just said yeah kick him in the
balls everyone knew what that meant
no now there's there's a real there's
technique to it booze uses that a lot
from there which you actually scoop the
groin
like that you can do you hit also with
the toe
more like that do you actually give him
a little a little
joint like that come on that's not fair
that's not right
even if you're just playing that's not
right look he he he doesn't like that
listen how did this innocent video get
to so much groin talk
with brian rose and dan love that way
but for now just
simple like that right yeah that's it
sorry
did he did he just do that simple like
okay
okay guys that's um wow what a great way
to in this video what a
beautiful surprise sometimes uh you're
just gifted a little surprise
and that is the lesson today now who is
your favorite
martial artist tell me why in the
comments below and the top
rated uh fighter so if you say like dan
lok
and you'd like to unlock upvote the top
rated one the top rated one
wins at the end of i don't know a day
and i'll pin it at the top and they're
the official fighter of youtube
that's it for now see you next time i
know what you need
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee